Seventy years on, 300 elderly survivors gathered before Auschwitz-Birkenau's gate of death.
This is where the trains came, to a camp where over a million were killed:...
...the vast majority Jews,...
...but also Roma, homosexuals, Polish dissidents and Soviet prisoners of war.
This is the last anniversary with so many living witnesses.
Outside, the railway sidings where selection took place,...
...to work as slaves or to be gassed.
Wreaths were laid against the wall where prisoners were shot.
Those that could paid tribute to families and friends wiped out.
This anniversary will be the last one...
...in which a significant number of survivors will be present.
And there is a concern,...
...that without living witnesses, keeping the memories alive of what happened here...
...and the lessons it teaches us and future generations will be much harder.